has Amazon actually listened to the fans
and are prepared to give us what we
want
really this might be the first time this
has ever happened welcome to sidere your
Sci-Fi TV and movie
[Music]
Chanel I'm a live yesterday with MGM
Insider Jenny styven somebody that's
actually worked on several big projects
for MGM we were discussing where we
think the Stargate franchise is right
now now we are speculating a lot but we
do have some confirmed information that
is pointing to a very interesting
possibility and since that conversation
with Jenny I was inspired to get in
touch with somebody that I know still
works closely with MGM and they gave us
a little bit more confirmation that
really starts to make
one possibility look very
promising and that possibility is that
MGM and Amazon might be about to scrap
plans to do a Stargate straight to
cinema movie and instead go back to the
original plan of giving us a straight to
streaming series
instead so first of all what are the
confirmed bits of information that we've
got again thanks to Jenny styven this
was confirmed last night on the live
there will be a link in the description
by the way so you can go and watch the
whole thing honestly Jenny has some
amazing insights into the industry and
if you like being able to see behind the
curtain a little bit of how the film and
TV industry works it's definitely worth
a watch and we want to back on at some
point so please get in there and check
that video out so we have two bits of
really good information one just over
two weeks ago now there was quite a big
meeting over at Amazon at C Studios this
meeting basically was called by a couple
of the top Executives um including
Jennifer Suki to basically thrash out
conversations about whether they should
do a movie or a TV series now we've
reported several times over the last 12
months there have been quite a lot of
arguments between Executives at MGM and
Amazon about whether they should do a
movie whether they should do a series as
well as that argument though there's
been quite bit of debate about whether
this is something they should just crack
on and get done or whether they should
take their time and actually push down
the calendar and actually make sure they
get right first time but we're going to
ignore that conversation for the Moment
movie series so basically Jennifer sui
told the people that keep arguing that
this should be a series to come in to
Culver Studios and present their
argument I have this mental image of
some executive there with glasses and
going and this as shows projections for
the movie of you know like a flow chart
or a pie chart I expect lots of charts
at the end of the day Amazon love
metadata so they're going to have looked
and analyzed this and the way that that
data is then interpreted is very
important somebody at the end of the day
has interpreted a lot of this metadata
and decided that a movie was the way to
go now we've actually had this
conversation a couple of times I
actually believe and this is not in my
opinion but I actually believe Jennifer
suy is the person that has basically
decided to do a movie simply because the
money was already budgeted for it Amazon
had already budgeted to do five or six
cinematic movies a year so Jennifer S
just went let's give one of them to
Stargate and that was as far as really
the thought went but a lot of the data
and a lot of the analysis has been done
since we over at cidre pretty much
dropped that announcement w
nearly a year ago and the conversations
have continued now we know for a fact
and this was again confirmed last night
by Jenny styen we know for a fact that
Amazon were planning to announce this
movie at San Diego Comic conon four
months ago they didn't because of the
strikes we know for a fact that was
going to be for a movie a theatrical
cinematic movie we know since then
they've been talking to a few directors
but we know that none of them have
signed on we know for a fact that all of
the studios while the strikes have been
running have been reviewing and going
over all of their projected projects
everything they were planning to
basically do in the next five years
they've reviewed loads of Studios have
cancelled loads of projects Netflix for
example cancelled the He-Man liveaction
movie even though they'd already spent
million on development so all of the
Studios have gone through this process
so it's not a big leap to assume that
Amazon have done exactly the same in
fact we know they have then we know for
a fact that the Monday following this
presentation there was another meet in
Amazon and I know for a fact from one of
my sources that Stargate and a decision
over Stargate was on that agenda now at
the time we believed that was going to
be about when the project was going to
be announced but now actually speaking
of somebody else I've realized that
actually that was an assumption because
the bulk of the day was about when other
projects were going to be announced
things like RoboCop Stargate apparently
was a separate conversation it just
happened to be done on the same day we
don't actually know what they were
talking about we don't know what the
decision was they were supposed to be
making about Stargate we've assumed and
they know what you say about assumption
it makes an ass out of you and me so
what if the decision wasn't about
whether they should be announcing it now
what if the decision was about whether
they should change the
plan they have a meeting just a few days
before discussing whether actually a
series is the best way to go and then
they have a meeting just a few days
later later I don't think that's an
unfair assumption for once and what my
other sources has told me since the live
with Jen makes that possibility a little
bit more likely but there is one other
little bit of information something I
shared with you just over three four
weeks ago now as well the pr are
marketing companies over at MGM and
Amazon they were asked to review all of
the big sci-fi projects that were going
to be announced over the next 12 to 18
months and this was going to be done
through Amazon MGM pictures distribution
so everything the Amazon MGM pictures
Distribution Company were going to be
planning to be released in the next 18
months they had to review the strategy
for all of that PR marketing Stargate
was not included now at the time I said
there's two possibilities for that one
is that they' decided to scrap it
they're not just going to do it and I
said that unlikely the other possibility
is they were about to announce it well
well now we've realized there's a third
possibility what if they pulled that
from the marketing review because in
fact they're going to change direction
and whatever they planned previously for
Stargate is no longer
relevant so before I tell you about the
other person I've spoken to let's just
discuss why things might have
changed one the strikes they have
changed a lot about what is going on in
Hollywood right now they have made all
of the executives stop and think it's
given the management the opportunity to
stop and think which means they've had
time to reconsider things never a good
idea for a manager to have that
opportunity in my experience of
work but that is one thing also the
negotiations mean that the financial
situation in the next 18 months to 5
years is going to have
changed how much studios are going to be
paying out out because of the new
contract is going to have changed plans
that they had regarding things like AI
are going to have changed because of the
new contract and the new agreements
there are lots of things that are going
to mean the Studios have to have a stop
and a rethink now Amazon do have a
long-term plan that I don't think will
be massively affected by a lot of what
is going on with the strikes and the
other thing that's changed is basically
the fans have been shouting very loudly
that we don't want a movie this
opportunity for the studios to stop and
think has also given them an opportunity
to stop and look they can see channels
like citrek and the podcast brothers and
gate world and so on and so on all
shouting out very loudly we don't want a
movie everybody that's done a poll of
Stargate fans say they don't want a
movie 90% of people people that when we
did this and we had this conversation
which do you want do you want a movie or
a series 90% of people said we want a
series the other thing is though the
world of Cinema has changed big
franchises don't seem to be doing very
well and this year has really been a bit
of a shock to some of the big studios
Indiana Jones was never expected to lose
that much money and it wasn't because
the film was bad because as soon as it
went on streaming it did very well
mission impossible that did not do well
at the cinema you know I know Barbie and
hoppenheimer came out immediately
afterwards and sort of decimated it but
the truth is as well all of the Marvel
movies have not been doing very well all
the DC movies have not been doing very
well and it has made the studio stop and
think
franchises might not be for the cinema
anymore or at very least it's made them
stop and think about what they are going
to spend big money on pushing towards
the
cinema so that might be one of the
reason why we're going to get a series
instead of a movie now because of the
Chang in face of the cinema so after
speaking to Jenny I got in touch with
somebody else that I know that works
over MGM they are more to do with sort
of legal side of the business so they
get to see certain things I haven't
spoken to this person for a couple of
months because with the strikes there's
been no reason to but they got in touch
with me back this morning and we've had
a nice long chat one of the things
they've been able to confirm to me is
actually that penguin and a Parker are
still involved with the conversations
regarding Stargate and to me that is a
big relief it's again something that me
and Jenny spoke about last night I
personally haven't heard anything
concrete about penguin and the Parker
Mark Fergus and Hawk HBY the guys that
did um the expanse since basically last
December I knew they had a contract to
do development were negotiating a
contract to move that to the next step
and start doing scripts Etc there was
lots of conversations about whether it
was going to be a movie a series blah
blah blah and those contract
negotiations ended just before Christmas
quite friendly but with some frustration
on both parks so they hadn't been able
to sort of get an agreement Mark Fergus
apparently was quite frustrated actually
that there was no decision from Amazon
at the time about whether it was going
to be a movie or series and there was a
few budgetary things as
well now Jenny styen said she'd actually
heard that penguin and AP Parker was
still renegotiating that development
contract um much later in the year she
was not 100% certain but you know sort
of March April sort of time so the
source has been able to confirm to me
that while a lot of these contracts are
being renegotiated and actually signed
right now because the writers can sign
them again penguin AP Parker is
negotiated with Amazon and that is for a
Stargate related project that they're
currently finalizing that contract and
doing all the small print and that this
Source expects that to be done and
dusted within the next few weeks talking
to this Source though today he basically
confirmed a lot of what we've been
talking about yes Amazon has been
renegotiating lots of things they have
cancelled lots of projects that they
were talking about and they were
planning they have cancelled several
contracts to buy certain scripts they
were planning to buy 18 months ago that
they are no longer going to be moving
forwards with the source says that
they've been looking at no more Studio
space contract Etc and they're looking
very firmly at going a lot of this alone
that they are looking at a lot of
contracts abroad for Studio space one of
the things we talked about was that we
believed Stargate was going to be filmed
in Poland and he said yes there are is
Studio space that Amazon are rented out
in Poland right now so that is a
possibility I asked him about whether
it's true possibly actually that
Stargate project movie had gone to the
point of maybe building sets he said it
wouldn't surprise him he doesn't know
for certain himself but it wouldn't
surprise him in the slightest because he
is aware of at least eight other
projects that had got to the point of
early development I.E building stad
starting to actually do some of the
early CGI Stuff Etc that Amazon had now
cancelled he was actually able to tell
me that one of those projects was quite
a big project and they'd already spent 8
million on development and they just
scrapped so I asked him is it possible
that Amazon are changing tacted and that
they will just move everything from the
movie to the series that actually they
spent nearly a year on development work
before and he said it's not only
possible it's very likely he's basically
said that everything that he is seeing
at the moment is pointing to the fact
that Amazon are getting ready to get
back to work and they are more than
willing to change their minds if they
think there's a good reason to so okay
this is quite a long video summarizing a
lot of different points but the overall
point
is MGM insiders are telling us this is
possible a lot of the meetings and
things that we know happened even if we
don't necessarily know the results seem
to be pointing towards this possibility
we know that it's what Stargate fans
want we know it's what all of the
metadata that we've generated as
YouTubers points to finally I know for a
fact that the head of MGM plus Michael
Wright has been screaming and fighting
and scrapping to get Stargate over on
MGM plus from day one and it seems that
he might possibly have won the argument
but guys what do you think get into the
comments and tell me if this is true and
they do change tact I actually think
we'll get something on our screens about
the same time we ' got a movie anyway
it'll be 12 to 18 months so really it
won't make any difference except for the
fact that we'll get a series 10 hours at
least of streaming rather than a
two-hour movie is that exciting would
that be better it would give them a lot
more time to World build and get
everything straight from 15E Gap and to
be honest it's just what we want isn't
it get into the comments though and tell
me what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscri subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos as we talk about
Stargate all the time also you can go to
patreon.com citre where you get to see
most of our new videos first and finally
you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we write articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest please
go check it out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]